[Music]
these assholes are still sending Harry
back to live with abusive people during
the summer because Harry doing this he
didn't pull out a wand he did not have
any spell name so why does he have to
use that ever if he can silently will a
person he doesn't like to bloat up and
float away it's pretty damn convenient
that the Magic Bus shows up literally
just as Harry's about to have a
confrontation with the doll or
inconvenient because now this is
godfather who loves him and a lot of
worry and mystery could have been
alleviated if the bus had simply been
three minutes slower all that bull with
Ron Harry the flying car and the muggles
was a bunch of bull cat Wilhelm scream
[Music]
right cuz every other year at Hogwarts
has been peachy why would I go you think
somebody wants to kill me oh I don't
know the events of the last two movies
might lead someone to think that you've
checked for compartments since when do
professors ride along with students on
the train to Hogwarts Sirius Black
escaped from Azkaban to come off to you
know kid this age would ever tell
important secrets to their friends in
this close proximity to a teacher even
if they thought that teacher was asleep
it sure is lucky they picked the one
compartment where professor just
happened to be sleeping when did the
Hogwarts choir learn this song during
their summer break this is the first one
night of school or is this some kind of
school song or an annual tradition to
sing a song about something wicked
coming
unlike the Oracle the new dumbledore
feels no need to explain his alternate
appearance a word of caution dimensions
are vicious street shows this warning
came just in time
Dumbledore clearly said the Dementors
would be stationed at every entrance to
the grounds and instead they're all just
hovering out over the water already
they're fuck-ups I'd be scared except
Harry faces death every year and lives
so this is really just another day
the things you learn at the age of 13
I'm beginning to think the adults at
Hogwarts purposely withhold information
for sheer comic relief the director said
let's give you an apple to eat in this
scene so you'll look like even more of
an asshole anything that flies in the
Harry Potter universe is contractually
obligated to do some soaring laps over
Hogwarts castle it's great to see all
those Dementors still flying around and
doing their job oh wait hopefully
Buckbeak doesn't kill any of you while
I'm gone
Hermione isn't old enough to be hot yet
racist also there's nothing the entire
magical kingdom can do to find Sirius
Black if only he were stranded on the
side of the road needing a bed for the
night
also wizard newspapers make ridiculous
text layout decisions if Hermione is
using a time travel device so that she
can be in two places at once why would
Ron notice anything abnormal holy Sh she
just turned that Cobra into something
even scarier why is everyone laughing no
one else gets a turn because Harry
bogarted the Boggart
mother Lily's this dude totally your mom
hearing not a single professor inside
this castle would help Sirius back to
entrance there is no way these two would
have this conversation right in front of
students who are notorious for faking
sleep in order to eavesdrop Hogwarts is
a dick to safety
invisible Harry is an asshole also way
to give away your position assface I
thought you were supposed to be
incognito yeah that door always just
opens on its own no reason to think
that's suspicious
it sure is fortunate that the minister
of magic and Professor McGonagall decide
visit this random pub owner so that
Harry could hear some extremely crucial
information he could use later character
who really needs glasses loses glasses
during crucial action sequence cliche if
only there was a spell to improve one's
vision or if only those glasses were
stranded on the side of the road Nina
never mind
did the lobby windows branch stop so
that Hermione could grab him into Harry
oh man if you would only fall in right
side up oh well maybe next time Harry
with the pronoun game why scare the kid
when you mean to kill the rat well there
goes the theory that you need your own
personal wand to make magic so what was
all that both in the last movie with
Ron's broken wand at the school not
giving him a replacement also why is
Harry's disarming spell so strong that
it blasts Snape across the room while
Snape and lupins disarm expel nearly
disarmed the person so Lupin turned out
to be a good guy after all and so did
Sirius Black so this movie's primary
antagonist is Peter Pettigrew you were
you have horrible aim and once you knew
you were dragging Ron why did you keep
doing it all right because the werewolf
would totally be surprised by a sudden
full moon Hermione tries to reason with
the werewolf how did Snape not only miss
the freakin werewolf but not hearing him
howl just before he came out of the tree
is capturing a soul like winning the
Stanley Cup where everyone gets a chance
to kiss it before passing it along when
in doubt I find retracing my steps to be
a wise place to begin honestly can't you
just spell it exactly what they should
do instead of being such a vague bastard
is this not a mission in which you
actually want them to succeed hey you
know what might help with the whole
let's not be seen while we're
time-traveling problem a fucking cloak
that makes you invisible dude where was
all this anger when you first found out
about this
another more normal reaction would be oh
so that's what that was seriously
everyone in the execution party is
enamored with the countryside
not one cursory glance toward the animal
you were about to kill in the time it
took them to finally lure Buckbeak into
the woods and not a site the original
Hermione Ron and Harry should have seen
Hermione and Harry taking Buckbeak to
safety from atop the hill why his
Hagrid's house different in this movie
like before it was a one-room thing on
the edge of the evil forest now it's a
two room joining the edge of a cliff can
a werewolf really not tell the
difference between a real wolf and a
teenage girl screaming like a wolf if
while trying to hide from a werewolf you
back into a clearing you deserve to die
harry and hermione resigned themselves
to werewolf death instead of i don't
know casting a spell at it or something
ritual harry somehow didn't hear this
both okay so they did all the stuff they
need to do they say Buckbeak they
distracted the werewolf and Harry sent
dear Jesus toward the Dementors but
nothing to prevent Peter Pettigrew from
escaping couldn't they have spent a
little time figuring out what they
needed to do before they actually left
invisible cloak check rat glue traps
and/or Hermione's cat check I saw myself
conjuring the Patronus before I know I
can do it this time because
well I already done it does that make
sense yeah this awful terrible excuse of
a human being who escaped freaking
Azkaban probably doesn't need a guard or
anything while he's in this dinky
Hogwarts cell something like this might
work against two werewolf and also in
that mirror from the first movie which
you seem to have forgotten about
entirely
how come Sirius didn't have to do that
whole bowing ritual with Buckbeak in
order to be able to pat him on the head
and then ride up Harry and Hermione run
from the courtyard up a dozen flight of
stairs to the infirmary in about five
seconds flat straight we did it
good job saving the day don't ever use
that time machine again though no matter
how dire things get in future sequels
let's talk about the movies time travel
they go back in time but practically
everything we see them do is stuff that
happened the first time through Harry
getting hit with a rock distracting the
werewolf etc this is a paradox of
terminator proportions unless there's an
original unique experience where the
time-turner isn't being used harry and
crew would go to Hagrid's cabin and
likely get caught by Dumbledore then
none of the things we see happen what
actually happened they don't say fuck
big Ron doesn't lose his rat Sirius
doesn't brag wrong into the tree and
into the shack Harry doesn't find out
scabbards Peter Pettigrew Lupin turns
into a werewolf somewhere else and
Sirius doesn't get nailed by the
Dementors and scene the problem with
this though besides the fact that we in
the audience didn't get to see this
original experience is that at this
point only Buckbeak has been harmed and
you weren't using a time travel device
just to go back and save that asshole
they don't have any other motivation to
begin going back and trying to fix stuff
thus a paradox it made any difference as
you go escaped that's what I'm saying
[Music]
he's inside she's inside his room
Sirius Black
the fan is thrusting in the direction of
the problem to skip a day now and again
you know I used to be a werewolf I know
this is bad hold on to me The Book of
the Dead found in human flesh and inked
in blood
this ancient Sumerian texts contain
bizarre burial rites funerary
incantations and demon resurrection
passages it was never meant for the
world of the living
see if you want some deal can you quit
everyone started shutdown at cinemas oh
this motherfucker he's getting out like
he ain't got a care on the Lord who
knows maybe you don't maybe this fools
such a bad motherfucker